welcome back new research suggests just
how easily people can spread diseases
like coronavirus
simply by speaking as nancy nancy chen
reports researchers used a basic device
to get their results and say that not
all
face coverings offer equal protection
duke university researchers wanted to
test how easily germs can spread
even during normal conversations they
used a box
laser lens and cell phone camera to
visualize droplets
and film people speaking into the box
stay healthy people
it's astounding how much stuff comes out
of you when you just speak you don't
even have to sneeze or cough
it's the speaking itself that that
already generates lots of droplets you
may not know
that you're spreading the disease
you won't see it dr martin fisher and dr
eric westman's team
tested several types of face coverings
and 95s without valves were the best
protection and surgical masks were also
adequate
popular double layer cotton masks
provided good coverage as well
but coverings like bandanas and neck
fleeces did not
block droplets much and may actually
spread them more
everyone has been saying something is
better than nothing
but your study actually says that's not
the case
that is not the case you have this mesh
in front of you
these big droplets that you emit
actually get broken down by this type of
fabric
into a bunch of little droplets the
findings drive home how critical masks
are
especially since the coronavirus can
spread when someone doesn't have
symptoms
if you want to reduce your risk and
other people's risks of a
transmissible disease the science is
clear that you should wear
a mask wear a face covering because
researchers say
wearing masks is one step we can all
take
to help end this pandemic nancy chen cbs
news new york
researchers also emphasize the
protection health care workers needs
such as n95 masks are not necessary for
everyday
life i just i i really thought that by
doing
the mask that that was helping all the
times not so it's basically like
shredding it is what you said right
someone
showed me a trick and this is an extra
mask that i have so you got you got your
mask you do this test at home you take
the mask okay
and just take some water and just pour
some water to see how
is it holding it see nothing's coming
through my mask this is you know with
this surgical mask you can buy you can
get them anywhere
but look if you think about oh that's my
sponge well that was your fault that was
my fault
nothing's coming out of this mask so
that just shows that no pellets are
gonna get out of this mask
that's uh that's a good test there to
see if that works now i feel safe with
now you need a new method and i got a
new i got another on my back
i just got to hold this awkwardly during
the next segment that's all well a
survey by dr